I ain't worried about nothing top yeah
oh oh a nother whoa that's not misheard
it's a Caribbean accent oh no no it's
not Jamaican its Bajor God Chris you're
you'd be a little racist
I thought we voted the work came with
racism this year
[Music]
can you guys hurry up watch it my bones
it does electric baby when I turn it oh
is that what I took a pill later itza to
show up easy yeah cool
oh sorry I don't do drugs yeah Chris
calm down Peter oh I don't like pizza
either what I even this is what you came
lightning Triceratops
and set this party on fire
players puja picky makers whoa legacy
fan art why you see panda packet for
diamonds salable cannon
[Music]
[Music]
oh my oh my god Wow oh my kid what can
you I'm in a couple why would I want to
he's still got it the only battle but a
tremendous battle a huge butthole but
all's love me waist as his masterpiece
waist down
she's a masterpiece we suck she's a four
I wouldn't I wouldn't don't need no
butterflies when you give me the whole
damn flu Star Trek grooving the Wrath of
Khan girls get loose when they hear the
song you know Wrath of Khan is actually
the best Star Trek film oh no no no it's
like great like a rolls-royce no eraser
from Lord of the Rings have a nice day
see you know what a nozzle allows guys
there no more girls at this party
[Music]
zombies
is there one one Asian baby I'm white
I'd love an Asian baby great headline oh
ha ha oh I am the new Brangelina
I stopped FLOTUS but you said you didn't
see her Oh
oh my god up inside you sound too
innocent fancy-free son you don't know
what the song is about do you all right
yeah just when you get time
that's what her wrist icicle is I'm
gonna start going to church again I
think play that song okay come on guys
that's too literal cut left this again
[Music]
oh Jesus
no more no let's move on I hate this no
why why do we have to do these mister
lyrics by 2016
see you later